in Blackford joins me now a very good
morning to you in Blackford we'll come
on to your calls for a general election
in a moment first of all though what do
you make of Liz truss's resignation
happy to see her go
well I'm relieved that she's gone it's
been a challenging few weeks hasn't it
and of course the it's been one big
Financial experiment and it's one that's
gone horribly wrong uh the impact it had
in the financial markets the fact the
bank of England had to step in decline
in the pound but perhaps Above All Else
the fact that mortgage rates have risen
as sharply as they have there's a place
to be paid for all of this she should
never have been prime minister this was
a March to the right that we had with 20
party members over the summer and the
leadership election they're all looking
to outdo each other but my goodness it's
been unedifying she singularly was unfit
for for office and I think now we've got
a conservative party a conservative
government that we're really out of
touch with the electorate and that is
why in the situation that we're in this
morning the right responses for the
people of all these islands right across
the United Kingdom to have a say in a
general election
well you
you want that general election but it's
in the gift of the prime minister so
it's just not going to happen is it
well I think my message to certain MPS
is to recognize where we all are
recognize that this is a government
that's out of time that that played fast
and loose with our financial well-being
over the course of the last few weeks
and they need to accept that they've
lost that moral authority to government
they need to act not just in their
narrow party interests but act in all
our national interests and the response
to that is to make sure that the people
right across these islands have their
seat in a general election
well if there was a general election now
and as I say it looks very unlikely
given that it's the Prime Minister that
would have to call it labor looks set to
win according to the latest polls so
would you rather see labor in power than
the conservatives would you support a
labor government
but I want people to have the right to
have their say of course I don't want to
see conservative governments we've
always supported uh Progressive politics
but I would say too whoever's going to
be in down the street from whatever
party that they have to respect
democracy and Scotland and they have to
respect the right of the Scottish
Parliament to be able to enact the
Mandate that we have from an
independence referendum but here in
Scotland there's been a number of polls
over the last few weeks the only one
that counts when people go out to vote
but all the ports in Scotland actually
show that the SNP would increase the
number of MPS that we have in Scotland
the Tories would be wiped out if they're
an election today but we need to make
sure the people in Scotland have the
right to give their verdict on
Westminster governments and be able to
reflect on the offer that we have of
taking Scotland back into the European
Union the pain that we've had of being
out of the European Union to be able to
reverse that and to get the investment
that we lead in this college economy
particularly in the green energy sector
as we seek to deliver on our promise to
get to Net Zero by 2045 so working
contrasting two Futures staying with
Westminster with the underachievement
the under delivery that was seen or a
different future for us a better future
of Scotland taking its place back in the
family of nations in the European Union
what do you make of the suggestion this
morning that Boris Johnson might run for
the leadership
horrified
I mean this was a man that was taken out
of office quite simply because he
disrespected the Office of Prime
Minister one that millions of people
were appalled by his behavior over the
covet crisis the partying that took
place in 10 Downing Street our prime
minister let's remember the only prime
minister in history that was found
guilty of breaking the law violent
office and a prime minister that's still
got to come in front of the primologies
committee over his behavior while he was
in office
I have to question what 20 MPS are
thinking that they believe it to be
reasonable that Boris Johnson should be
brought back again it should never be
allowed anywhere near public office
well whoever wins and we don't know if
Boris Johnson will run how important is
it that the next prime minister reaches
out to Nicola sturgeon she said that Liz
truss didn't call her in her six weeks
in office how much of a problem do you
think that was
of course it's a it's a problem you know
we have our practical differences and
that's right that we
you know show people exactly what we're
trying to do where these differences
exist but when it's right it's also
equally important that we work together
let me give you an example of Ben
Wallace the defense secretary because he
has worked across party with all Party
leaders to make sure that we all Stand
Together against Putin against that
illegal war in Ukraine and to make sure
that we support our friends in Ukraine
and to see not just less trust but Boris
Johnson before that that showed that or
disrespect for the government in in
Cardiff in Edinburgh is simply not
acceptable that the normal protocols in
office need to exist and it comes down
to that lack of appreciation of
understanding about how those in the
highest offers need to interact with
colleagues that have responsibility in
government as well
well in black but SMP leader at
Westminster thanks very much indeed for
your time this morning